one of the clients used to meet them at
lunch time and I'd land the end of my
bed with my head on the end of the bed
she'd pull her up [__] to one side and
sit on my face and I'd do what I'd done
and she'd leave some people asked me to
put him in a cage and just leave them
there for an hour and abuse them Chuck
some water on them and stuff and they
pay you for that I mean that's just
ridiculous the threesome seems to be the
most popular thing these days everybody
wants a threesome everybody like I said
four hours later everyone's very happy
but again I'm not sure about the four
hours bro that's a long one for me like
I've been in groups of 100 people and
sometimes the light has been off and I
don't even know if it's a woman to
handle a man's hand just grab that you
know cocaine was a massive thing let's
just take it hard on the table Yeah but
that ain't just the one pile how often
were you working in covert that was the
most busiest
I have never been so busy I've never had
so many messages
the true Geordie podcast